welcome to this video on chess IPO one
from Austria let's see what I can do
here so let's do something else he lied
that it's not seen very often in my
videos with f3 why not probably a quick
we should be three Queen d2 makes sense
to prevent Bishop g5 trades okay I
actually have a 100-percent score
against this guy four out of four so
something to to keep job see getting in
b5 mmm I don't know maybe the bishop is
wrong here to be honest if Black gets in
b5 this is normally helping him but
maybe I'm just quick enough with playing
em a form interesting Jim it's hard to
not play this move to be honest if he
gets in b5 it helps him tremendously ok
so this night is coming to be form
let's do this and the other night here
yep Jack that's not so bad for like it's
got decent decent pieces here don't
don't see a really great plan here at
the moment what can I do okay i can what
i can do is i can try to trade
LightSquared bishops this would be a
nice strategic achievement let's try it
Bishop g5 I can take these six that's
not really on I can take this six here
okay oh I see no I don't get it let's
see okay so we can even trade queens and
then take you six so he gave me this
pawn let's see I still would like to
trade the bishops I wonder how can i do
that the night is very nicely
controlling important 1c8 square let's
cover a for Bishop e2 should be to be
high F would be excellent to get in now
the only issue really is that his
knights are also very active yeah they
are kind of yeah jumping around but
still
cakes and negative B 5 controls d4 so 94
I can just take and what I what I need
is with a bit of coordination and the
knight on c3 is some not so great it's
just basically doing the same thing that
the other night is doing so that kind of
yeah there are kind of redundant let's
see where to get that to see for would
be nice but ok I can ok night a to maybe
to try it
d 6 check I really don't know about that
one this is a good idea yeah he's got
possibly rook c8 or something okay let's
let's do that takes Knight takes look
there is good she has no kind of counter
attack I mean he's not gaining the C
file rook c8 not before not before Luke
c1 is okay black resigns ok that was
early I mean okay it's a very bad
position but but anyhow okay let's let's
have a look here how this went he
basically blundered the d6 pawn before
that here I think this is certainly an
okay position for black cannot be cannot
be too terrible I have this this nice be
five square but he has those outposts
here as well and jam I think he probably
should should do something like that
putting in some pressure on my my Center
my bishop d1 neglected this idea a
little bit but I have to I have to
follow some kind of plan and the Bishop
e2 plan to try to trade on b5 is kind of
kind of useful yeah probably has to do
that so interesting it can play Queenie
aid on a move like that that's just
complex maybe it's about equal stuff to
say I don't have something in particular
here but this is just giving away the
porn right yeah it's just a pawn and
this night is of course not expert
exactly in a bad spot there
no no just consolidating a little bit i
think this puzzle wasn't ki trading
those bishops is good here actually when
I think of it I could have I could have
played differently here I could have
done that and then maybe night back to
see for pressure rising b68 was met this
was better right that was a it was a bad
idea I mean okay it's not giving away
much because well I have this very very
static advantage of the pawn on d5 but
it was better for the for the Knights
and here this is just a bit of a
technical plane trading this yeah I
think probably best that you can do is
let's say take cake and rook c8 and see
I'm have to try to get rooks on the sea
fowl let's see maybe also here here's an
idea yeah well it's just it's just the
big pony on d5 we cannot cannot really
compensate for that okay well thanks for
watching